Скажіть що сьогодні відбулося в Лаврі
вітаю ну як добре хтось написав
розпочалася служба Служба безпеки
України ми бачили що відбувалося обшуки
в києво-печерській Лаврі і також є
повідомлення про обшуки в Корецького
монастирі який відомий тим що дуже
глибоко інтегрований якраз в структурі
російської Православної Церкви тому дуже
Сподіваємось що це буде результативні
заходи і що ми скоро почуємо про те що
знайдено І про що це свідчить а
Розкажіть будь ласка в чому проблема
московських попід чому в тому що вони
московські попри те що 27 травня
відбувся собор на якому вони всіляко
розповідали про те що вони порвали
нібито з російською Православної Церкви
власне з Московським патріархатом але
по-перше вони не публікують свого нового
статуту тому що те що там експерти
журналісти на запит отримали це надто
довгий шлях все-таки ще студентів вчать
що спочатку треба щоб документ був
опублікований в документ загальної дії
тоді він набуває чинності цього не було
але навіть в тому що ми бачимо там є
перший пункт який говорить що так званий
це незалежність церкви Вона виходить з
грамоти Московського Патріарха яка в
свою чергу говорить про те що УПЦ є
фактично в зв'язку з російською
православною церквою через неї має
стосунки з іншими тобто стверджується
оце єдність вона нікуди не ділась і тому
абсолютно більшість експертів оглядачі в
регієзнавців говорить про те що
збереглася зв'язок і це є певна димова
завіса Ну і сьогодні ви чули пісков
фактично з полив контору сказавши що цей
обшук СБУ - це війна з російською
Православної Церкви тобто якби не треба
було таке експертних доказів то рашисти
самі і все називають своїми іменами так
А в чому типу проблема фактично Ну от
проводять люди службу російською Ну і що
перше і найголовніше Російська
православна церква - це більше ніж
церква в тому сенсі що це є продовження
російської державної машини у впливі
науми на проведення ідей так званого
Русского Мира який До речі у
кристалізувався в тому числі
московськими папами в тому числі в
оточенні нинішнього патріарха гундяєва і
це є фактично така велика ідеологічна
машина з обливання громадян не хочу
звичайно узагальнювати бо є там
насправді священники які не соромлять
свого сану а ми бачили що кількадесятних
звернулася щодо засудження патріарха
гундяєва але на жаль це там меншість а
ми бачимо от зокрема по матеріалах
обшуків які були раніше у Вінницького
Митрополита яка там є література яка там
є агітація за Руській мир який там є
матеріал на розкол українського
суспільства от за все це має бути
відповідальність і уж точно має бути
відповідальність за колаборантство за
наведення російських ракет за здачу на
окупованих територіях українських
патріотів ветеранів російсько України і
всі інші випадки колаборантства ну
зрештою якщо їх навіть
СБУ називає колаборанти в рясах то я
думаю він має на це підстави А питання
мені говорили що
московські попив точніше російська
церква вона заважала отримувати томос
чому Ну тому що у них була одна така
теза яка важлива для віруючих людей що
мовляв українська церква тоді Київського
патріархату Українська автокефальна
православна церква вони мовляв не
благодатні і вони мовляв не канонічні
вимовляли справжні То куди вже
справжніше якщо є Вселенський патріарх
який є перший серед рівних серед
ієрархів православних церковних
предстоятелів який свою Воле як це було
з усіма православними церквами надав
томос тобто визнав незалежну українську
православну церкву автокефальну яка сама
собою керує то Таким чином відпав цей
аргумент український православні якраз
мають об'єднатися в тій Церкві яка є
українською Яка власне пов'язана з
Україною а ми не бачимо будь-якого
бажання з УПЦ це визнати ми бачимо якісь
абсолютно нелогічні абсолютно
неприродні вимоги щодо початку
переговорів мовляв ви спочатку
плінтурний томос розеріть його визнаєте
що ви не канонічні і не благодатні ну це
дурниць це ніхто робити не буде І от в
чому якраз ви питаєте в чому проблема
московських копів їх раз проблема в тому
що вони не хочуть вийти з російського
розколу бо ми бачимо що Російська
православна церква розірвала стосунки з
вселенським православ'ям УПЦ так само в
цьому розколі Російська православна
церква не визнає тих Хто визнав пцу і
УПЦ так само і третя найголовніше
Російська православна церква не
співслужить з пцу не визнає таїнств і
УПЦ так само от Якщо ці три пункти вони
скасують тоді ми можемо говорити що вони
нам Московська Церква
А чому вони заважали отримати томос От
якби Україна його не отримала щоб було а
вони би далі розказували що вона єдина
канонічна церква що все інше Це не
благодатна і знов таки це аргумент на
багатьох віруючих людей може справляти
вплив А так навіть цей аргумент знищено
а для держави Україна це було якраз
однією з підставлених займатися томосом
бо по-перше це питання безпеки ви
говорили про вплив науми а друга І дуже
важлива і воно десь рівнозначне бо це є
забезпечення прав віруючих те що вони не
мають бути в пригніченому стані в те що
вони не мають бути в якомусь
другорядному стані а вони є визнані в
вселенським православ'я вони є долучення
до всієї православної християнської
спільноти І відтак можуть вільно
здійснювати і реалізовувати свій
релігійні потреби А скажіть будь ласка Я
читав що шукали дрг
шукали напевно також зброю там ще щось
Чи могли щось таке там знаєте мені дуже
цікаве думати всім громадянам України Я
дуже сподіваюсь що Служба безпеки
України сказавши а не дуже затягуватиме
з власне розповіді які букви йдуть в
світ за цією першої літерою по Якщо так
зроблено анонс то суспільство точно має
право знати що ж знайдено і Хто яку
відповідальність понесе за те що оте про
за чим приходилось СБУ отам зберігались
Клас дякую вам дуже